so Hogwarts Legacy drops not one but two
new clips this week they're very short
however it actually caused me to go back
and look at the previous two trailers
that we've gotten and I think I found
something that I haven't seen a lot of
people discussing so the first post is
here October 18th where will the grand
staircase lead you and a very nice shot
here during the daytime looking up at
the grand staircase you have the winged
boars over here on the right and you can
see a few portraits moving around kind
of here in the middle but other than
that not really a whole lot going on
here okay so then we have the second
post which also came on October 18th and
this one says the castle isn't only
meant to be explored during the day
super exciting here that they seem to be
really playing up the idea of us being
able to sneak around Hogwarts at night
they've actually talked about this a
number of times lately including when
they mentioned the restricted section of
the library as well as us being able to
sneak around the Forbidden Forest now
this shot here appears to be the exact
same one as before however it is set at
night so only a few differences here
first of all you have the flame names
over here on the right just above the
waned boars and now all of the lamps are
set to be on as well now I'm not sure if
this was intentional or if we're
supposed to read anything into it at all
but the second one the one that's set at
night there is no audio at all you just
hear the crackling of the fire whereas
the first one in the daytime actually
has music playing along with it so I
don't know if this means there's not
gonna be any music at night and maybe
instead we're focusing on the sounds of
the game and trying to sneak around you
know you're trying to be stealth so you
need to hear everything that's going on
I'm not sure but I did think it was an
interesting choice to see that we don't
have any nighttime music with this one
now during our recent live stream right
here on YouTube if you guys haven't
checked it out before we stream every
Tuesday night here we talk all things
Hogwarts Legacy and someone in my chat
actually mentioned hey did you notice
that none of the staircases are moving
here you know even though this is a
video clip we don't really see a whole
lot of movement there's a few things
kind of moving around with portraits and
we see one of those books flying around
again but in terms of the stairs they
aren't moving and anyone who's a fan of
Harry Potter Knows oh it's keeping on
the staircases they like to change we
read about this in the book of course we
see it in the movie and to be honest I
was never really a big fan of how it
worked in the movie I mean they kind of
just swivel all the way around it's
almost mechanical in nature rather than
feeling like it's actually magic however
we got a glimpse of what we thought this
was going to look like in the first
reveal trailer for Hogwarts Legacy take
a look at it here and I love this I
thought this was great I loved how it
appeared on screen and how everything
just sort of magically fell into place I
thought this felt way more like a magic
school than what we saw in the movies
however Troy Levitt former Hogwarts
Legacy Dev mentioned on an interview
with podcasts now that this was change
take a listen to this clip right here
from Troy here's what I'll say about the
grand staircase the early version that
you saw in the very first trailer uh is
different than I think what you end up
in the game so there you go there's
there's a small small reveal what we
discovered about making the the stairway
build up like that you know because it
was like you can see it in the film it
was building up underneath you well it's
too slow for players right players
didn't want to wait for the thing to
come around so we had to come up with a
fast faster way to make the grand
staircase do its thing that wouldn't
slow players down and that's a lot of
what you're doing when you're making a
game as you're like thinking oh that's
really cool what's it like when you
experience it dang it's a little too
slow or the timing's off well we need to
adjust it make it better you know that
it's a very iterative process it's
always responding you don't know what
you have in a game until you experience
it and and I think it's really important
for players and developers to recognize
that you can talk all day long about
what you think would be good but until
you actually get in and play it and
experience it you don't know what you
have so knowing this this caused me to
go back and look at the more recent
trailer and see if there were any shots
at all of the staircase do we see this
new animation that Troy is talking about
here because my first thought was ah
they probably made it just like the
movies but no that's not what they did
instead we do get a very very brief
Glimpse I think at least of how this is
going to work in the state of Play
trailer let's take a look right here and
you'll see that instead of them kind of
forming and just being all scattered as
they appear here now we have sort of
these individual pieces of the stair
sliding in from left to right there and
while I don't think I like it better
than the first option that we saw on
that original trailer I do like it
better than how the movies handled it so
again the state of Play trailer that's
been a while as well it'll be
interesting to see if they have changed
this yet again whenever we get another
update whenever we see a more extensive
trailer or who knows whenever we play
the final game but if you listen to that
full interview with Troy there are
definitely some interesting things to
think about in terms of how it actually
affects gameplay he mentions that the
first option was just too slow for
players and so they were having to get
there and then kind of wait on the
stairs to form instead of them just
naturally forming as the player walks
now in my head I'm like couldn't you
just speed that up but Troy knows way
more about making games than I do so I
trust him when he says this is something
that's difficult to pull off and now it
seems that we get a brief glimpse of
what they have came up with as the
solution in this other trailer and I can
certainly see how these would be able to
slide in much faster just kind of as
each stair appears here rather than
having all these individual pieces of
the stair kind of floating around and
forming now if you want to check out the
full stream where I break this down in
real time with my chat I do keep vods of
all those up right here on YouTube in
fact I'll put this most recent one right
here on the right side of your screen
now check it out as always thank you all
so much for watching I'll talk to you
again soon